>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Rebecca Brasington Clark:
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
This is a very familiar place to
many of you, but we're so delighted
to see such a robust turnout for
this event, Mapping the Wilderness
of Knowledge, the Card Catalog
Past, Present and Future.
This event is being recorded
for future webcasting,
so please take a moment
if you haven't already
to silence your phone or tablet
or device of your choice.
My name is Becky Brasington Clark.
I'm the Director of the
General Publishing Office
at the Library of Congress.
Our office is charged with
promoting the library's collections
and scholarship through
the publication
of books and other products.
Today's program was inspired by the
release of a new book, this one,
The Card Catalog, Books, Cards
and Literary Treasures written
by my colleague, Pete Deveraux,
co-published by Chronicle Books
in association with the
Library of Congress.
He will kick off this afternoon's
program with a broad history
of the card catalog featuring
highlights from the book.
He will then turn the program
over to Beacher Wiggins,
the library's Director
for Acquisitions
and Bibliographic Access
who will then introduce
and join our stellar
lineup of speakers.
I hope you'll join us
immediately following the program
for the reception and book signing.
Books are for sale out in the foyer,
and we'll do the signing
out there as well.
We do have coffee, tea and cake,
and if you haven't seen
it, it's not just any cake.
It's a card catalog cake.
So we're geeking out on that.
Before we begin, I would like to
offer sincere thanks to Beacher
and his colleague, Susan Morris,
for developing this program
and supporting the participation
of our out of town speakers.
I'd also like to thank our
co-publisher, Chronicle Books,
whose generous support
made this event possible.
Thanks very much to Wanda
Cartwright and her colleagues
in the Special Events Office,
and extra special thanks
to publishing office
colleagues, Anna Freeze,
who managed every detail of this
process with enthusiasm, efficiency
and good humor and Marietta
Sharperson who navigated us
through some last minute
administrative mazes.
On the fly here, I want to
thank Dwight and Keith and Blane
and all the other chair herders
for stepping up to the plate
and just getting some
extra chairs on the floor.
Thank you very much.
Now, I'd like to introduce
Pete Deveraux, a writer,
editor in the Publishing Office
and author of The Card Catalog.
Pete's career was launched in
the scholarly publishing sector
where he worked for
Lippincott, Williams and Wilkins.
He left Lippincott
to become a librarian
at the Enich Pratt Free Library
where he had the privilege
of working alongside Carla Hayden.
Upon joining the Library of
Congress Publishing Office in 2012,
Pete brought together his
publishing and library experience.
He's contributed to or edited six
additional books for the library
and we are really fortunate
to call him our colleague.
Thank you very much.
Pete Deveraux.
[ Applause ]
>> Pete Deveraux: Well,
thanks Becky.
It's an honor to be here
with my esteemed colleagues
from the cataloging community.
I'd also like to thank Hanny
from the Publishing Office
for helping put this event together.
This book was a great opportunity
to tell a story about an unherald
yet extremely important part of
the libraries, the card catalog,
one of the most versatile and
durable technologies in history.
The reality is most card
catalogs are long gone.
We're not sure how many
people realize what a massive
and unprecedented undertaking
it was.
So I hope people will pick the
book up and read about the history
and continued importance
of cataloging here
at the Library of Congress.
So what I'd like to do is
briefly run through a fairly brisk
and general history of cataloging
in a progression towards the Library
of Congress' card catalog.
When I started research for this
book, I struggled a little bit
with finding a starting
point that made sense.
After reading about Somarian
historian, S.N. Kramer,
I understood the story really
started at the dawn of civilization.
He clearly identified one
[inaudible] tablet found near the
ruins of [inaudible]
dated around 2000 B.C.
as being used for cataloging
purposes.
At just 2.5 by 1.5 inches,
the tablet foreshadowed the
use of small index cards.
It was divided into two
columns listing the titles
of 62 literary works including
the epic of [inaudible].
From Mesopotamia, the next stop is
the ancient library of Alexandria.
The collection consisted
of papyra scrolls.
Organizing the library
proved very difficult
as scrolls had no title page, table
of contents or even author listed.
The Greek poet and scholar,
[inaudible] was chosen
to devise a way to provide access.
This cataloging of the scrolls
called the [inaudible] made him one
of the most important
figures in library history.
He completed around 250 B.C. It was
arguably the first time anyone made
a sophisticated list of
authors and their works.
From the surviving fragments,
scholars deduced the scrolls were
divided into separate classes
such as poetry, philosophy and
law and then further subdivided
into a narrow range of subjects.
Moving ahead some 1700 years,
once Gutenberg's printing
press was established,
books spread quickly
across the continents.
As publishing grew, there
emerged a uniformity
in the layout and design of books.
Title pages, table of contents
and other conventional
elements started to appear.
As it applied to cataloging,
this information was a game
changer though the staggering number
of books being printed
was unexpected
and ancient libraries during the
renaissance struggled to keep up.
Rising to the challenge, Swiss
bibliographer, Conrad Gesner,
brought cataloging into the modern
era with his ambitious attempt
at compiling a list of Latin,
Greek and Hebrew books in print.
Gesner spent years traveling
around Europe visiting libraries,
collecting bookseller
and publisher's lists.
In 1545, the first volume of
his Bibliotheca Universalis,
the universal library,
was published.
It included an exhaustive
alphabetical listing
of over 2000 authors and titles.
The work established Gesner
as the father of bibliography.
So what many consider the first
national library card catalog
happened during the chaos
of the French Revolution.
In 1791, the assembly issued
instructions to local officials
to be in cataloging libraries
that had been confiscated
from exiled or executed aristocrats.
The method relied on playing cards,
which were then blank on one side.
Playing cards were a perfect choice.
They could be purchased
throughout France.
They were sturdy and roughly the
same size no matter what brand,
and they could easily be interfiled.
Within three years, over
a million cards were sent
to the overwhelmed offices in Paris.
The original books of the Library of
Congress did not survive for long.
The collection went up
in flames just 14 years
after they were acquired whe
the British ransacked Washington
in 1814, torching the
White House and capitol.
When news of the fire reached
former President Thomas Jefferson,
he wrote to a friend
in Congress and offered
to sell his personal library.
Jefferson adapted his
cataloging scheme
from Sir Francis Bacon's system that
started with three main categories,
memory, reason and imagination.
Later modified by Jefferson through
history, philosophy and fine arts.
These categories were broken down
further into 44 distinct chapters
that fully encompassed
the entire collection.
By the mid 1800's, major
developments were happening
in the library community led
by Smithsonian librarian,
Charles Duwet [assumed spelling] who
sought to "form a general catalog
of all the books in the country
with reference to libraries
where each might be found."
At Harvard, assistant librarian,
Esra Abbott, is actually credited
with creating the first
modern card catalog.
His associate was Charles
Cutter, became librarian
of the Boston Anthenaum in 1868.
There, Cutter created a new scheme
that would later help establish
the basis for the Library
of Congress classification system.
Though Cutter's cataloging rules
were adopted by many libraries,
he is overshadowed by his
occasional rival, Melville Dewey,
whose approach to cataloging
was based
on a controlled vocabulary
represented by numerical values
that could be subdivided
by decimals.
It immediately caught on and
expanded Dewey's influence
within the library community.
Around this time, Anesworth Rand
Spotford became the sixth Library
of Congress.
And his approach to cataloging
and managing the growing collection
was much more idiosyncratic
than the emerging transient
professional librarianship.
In his view, "The organization
of a library is a subjective one.
I think the best system in
classifying a library is
that which produces a
book in the shortest time,
and this is a great picture of
the old library in the capitol
of the chaotic scene that rumor
has it only Spotford could find
the books.
This quote from Spotford stood
in direct contrast to librarians
that signed on as charter members
of the American Library Association.
The first issue of its official
publication made clear the most
pressing issues facing libraries was
the lack of standardized catalog.
For Dewey [inaudible], establishing
these standards was only half
the battle.
The growing number of libraries
across the country, they advocated
for a cooperative cataloging agency
that would issue cards
from a central location.
And the newly expanded Library
of Congress seemed the
natural fit to take the lead.
Shortly after opening
the new library building,
Herbert Putnam became
librarian in 1899.
And JCM Hansen and Charles
Martel were appointed
to lead the new cataloging division.
They confronted a collection
of more than 800,000 books,
hardly any of which had
been cataloged by subject.
Hansen later wrote that when
faced with this incredible job,
"There was no printed
or written rules,
no definitive verbal instructions.
Apparently, it will be part
of the wisdom to cut loose
from the old catalog all together."
It was therefore decided to
begin an entirely new catalog
on standard sized cards
3 by 5 inches.
With the larger staff, catalogers
created a new classification system
inspired by Cutty and Dewey as well
as integrating a new
system of subject headings.
In 1901 with its own dedicated
branch of the printing office
in the basement and equipped with
new [inaudible] type machines,
the library began to crank out
cards at a rate of 225 titles a day
and nearly 70,000 a year.
The titles were printed on the
best linen ledger stock 40 cards
to a sheet.
They were then cut into
bindery to the index size
and a hole was punched in
the bottom for the guardrail.
Upstairs the cataloging
division worked long,
hard hours doing the tedious work
of classifying, proofing, revising,
sorting and filing
the millions of cards.
On October 28, 1901,
more than half a century
after Druett suggested the federal
government centralize the printing
and distribution of catalog
cards, Putnam sent a memo to more
than 400 libraries announcing a
sale of its printed catalog cards.
In 1976, former Library of Congress
cataloger and historian, Paul Edlin,
wrote, "Few libraries have
been untouched by the work done
by library staff members
over the years.
It would be difficult to
walk into a library anywhere
in the United States,
be unable to find one
of these physical byproducts
of the intellectual efforts
of the cataloging staff of
the Library of Congress."
I think that's an appropriate quote
when introducing our next speaker.
Beacher Wiggins is the
Director for Acquisitions
and Bibliographic Access
at the Library of Congress.
He's been with the
library since 1972
and his present position since 2004.
He has been an active member of
the American Library Association
and the ALCTS Division of
ALA for more than 30 years.
And he recently was the winner
of the 2013 Melville Dewey
Medal Award sponsored by OCLC.
Beacher.
[ Applause ]
>> BeacherWiggins: Good
afternoon, everyone.
It's great to see you, and I have to
say I was given thanks for helping
and being cooperative
with this program,
and that's really all it was
because all thanks go to Susan
who was arranging this while
I was on travel this year.
And so I'm just doing
what I was told to do.
Even to the name of the very brief
remarks I'm going to make, the good,
the bad and the ugly, I'm not sure
I would have used any of those
for any number of reasons, but
hey, I try to stick to the plan,
which may be a reason
I've been around so long.
Now, it is obvious that
while I'm snowcapped
and I think you probably
can do deductions
that I've been around awhile.
In fact, yesterday I received --
was observed the 45th
anniversary ceremony here.
I'm not so old that I was
actually there and apart
of the market development.
So, we want to get
that straight upfront.
So now that we clarified that
point,my memories are going to be
and my remarks are going
to be vicarious in nature
and not because I was there.
But I did have the
privilege of working
with Henriette Davis Avrom
[assumed spelling] for five years
as her special assistant.
And as you might expect, I
gleaned a lot from that experience
in any number of ways that have
helped me in the following years.
Now, so I heard a lot
directly from her
as she orchestrated
the developmental mark
of automating the card catalog,
which we are here today celebrating.
In 1989, Lucia J. Rather who was
then LC's Director for Cataloging,
and I who at that time was a
special assistant to Henriette
who was the assistant
librarian for Library
of Congress Processing Services.
Lucia and I wrote an article for
American Libraries entitled MARK,
Mrs. Avrom's Remarkable
Contribution.
In preparing that article allowed
Henriette then to have time
to reminisce with Lucia and me
about the development of MARK,
about her involvement and her
assessment of MARK's evolution
and the transformation of
libraries for technical services
and public services librarians
and for catalog users everywhere
and of every [inaudible].
Now, the good.
When appointed to LC,
Henriette quickly recognized
that the most crucial aspect
of library automation was
to devise a standard vehicle for the
communication of bibliographic data.
The culmination of Henriette's
work was among several lasting
contributions was a format
structure that became the basis
for MARK'sformat worldwide and
the MARK distribution service,
a prototype that other national
bibliographic agencies emulated.
That same prototype, the MARK
distribution service, also gave rise
to the creation of
bibliographic utilities,
the foremost today being OCLC.
In fact, OCLC might have been here
at LC had Henriette gotten her way.
As forceful as she was, she wasn't
quite able to pull that one off,
but we'll talk about
that a bit in a minute.
Another technical achievement was
a process of format recognition.
That is a technique to enable the
computer to assign tags, indicators,
subfield codes, fix field codes
to machine readable
records from catalog cards.
Format recognition has been held as
one of the early examples in fact
of an expert or a thinking system.
All due to Henriette's foresight.
Now, the bad.
Henrietta viewed the RECON,
that is retrospective conversion
of catalog cards to MARK
data component as one
of the great missed
opportunities for libraries
in the development of MARK.
The library community did
not [inaudible] its resources
to convert all of LC's records
at that time dating from 1898
to machine readable form would have
advanced libraries immeasurably.
Without doing so, libraries
converted the same records
with high costs and varying
levels of quality which would end
up being a disservice to
library users everywhere.
In fact, libraries across
the country including LC
and we're working on some now
and I'm looking at a colleague
who have stewardship
of some that we need
to do are still converting card
catalogs and other manual files
that are in need of conversion.
So just think about that.
That was 50 years ago,
and we're still diddling
about with some hidden
connections to deep resources.
The ugly. When asked what she would
do differently in creating MARK,
Henriette [inaudible] that for the
LC MARK system she would not have
designed a separate application
for each form of material.
For those of us who were
around, I have to admit I was,
MARK rolled out with monographs,
serials of print materials.
Then it went to various formats.
In fact, I think it was into
early 1990's before we had all
of the formats ready and we were
no longer transcribing information
on sheets and cards, etc.
That failure necessitated format
integration in later years
of MARK's implementation and use.
Now, so as not to close on the bad,
I'll share a tidbit on how Henriette
who was not educated as a
librarian which fooled many people,
how she absorbed cataloging to such
a degree that she could develop MARK
and ultimately she could
be recognized as one
of the world's preimminent
librarians.
She was taught cataloging
through reading
and studying cataloging
rules and also by two Library
of Congress staff at the time.
One, a seasoned librarian.
Is Kay Collins in the audience?
That is he.
And along with a reference librarian
so you had on the one hand someone
who knew how to create the data
that went into catalog cards
and then you had one on
the other hand who knew how
to use and research that.
So she wanted to make sure
what she was doing was going
to be the full ticket.
So in addition to her bedtime
reading of the cataloging rules
which I understand she did on a
nightly basis from what she told me.
She had these two colleagues
who were working with her daily.
I'm told that one of
the learning tools
that she used was a large
facsimile catalog card.
She placed it on the floor and she
pressed top to bottom, left to right
and absorbing each element of
the card asking Kay questions
of what should be there,
what should not be there,
and when he couldn't answered,
he said, "Well, if we did it,
there must have been a reason for
having it so you ned to figure
out how to put it into the format."
So with that, I say long
live the card catalog
and its wanted legacy
even as we look forward
to its replacement bibframe, which
I won't go into because I've talked
about that to most of you, I think,
and I think our colleague will cover
a bit of that in a special format.
So thank you for your
attention to my remarks.
[ Applause ]
Now I'm simply going to go down
the [inaudible] and introduce each
of the colleagues, everyone of them
I've worked with, but I'm not going
through much introductory remarks
except to let you know who they are
and what their current
positions are.
The first will be Barbara
Natanson who works as head
of the reference -- head
of reference in Prints
and Photographs Division here
at the Library of Congress.
And I worked with Barbara
on numerous occasions
as we come together with both
guidance on processing materials
as well as the contents
of prints and photographs.
Then next to her is a colleague
from outside the library,
Christoper Cronin, who is
Director of Technical Services
at the University of Chicago, and
I worked with Chris on [inaudible].
He's a former PCC chair,and
I worked with him
on the so-called big
head's group at ALA.
So we have a good long
working relationship.
Next to him is Kathy Woodrell who
is here at the Library of Congress
and is a reference specialist in
decorative arts and architecture
in the main reading room.
And I worked with her on
many occasions including some
of our mentoring programs
and other areas.
And then last but certainly
not least is Jennifer Baxmeyer
who is a leader in serials
and electronic resources team
at Princeton University, and
I've had the privilege of working
with her both as we are
rolling out bibframe
and in the OCLC [inaudible],
OCLC Partners Group at ALA.
So these are our wonderful
speakers this afternoon,
and we're simply going in order
and at the end of the presentation,
we'll have time for
questions, comments
and your thoughts on
today's sessions.
So Barbara.
[ Applause ]
>> Barbara OrbachNatanson:
See if we can pull this down.
I feel like saying
can you see me now?
I also wanted to thank the
organizers for this program,
which gave me a chance to revisit
my life with the card catalog.
I see in the program that I'm listed
as talking about the card catalog
as early technology and
that probably should be
as my early technology.
I handled a lot of catalog
cards in my early career
in the Princeton Photographs
Division.
But as you'll see, I'm
think I'm going to argue
that the card catalog was really
advanced in technology with all
of its benefits and efficiencies.
The catalog helps us to envision
multiple aspects of access
to a large picture collection.
So see what we've got here.
So the Princeton Photographs
Division has a proud traditionof
using card catalogs.
We once counted 40
different card catalogs
and indexes and use in the division.
At this point, we've converted much
of that data into online records,
but there's still card catalogs in
regular use in our reading room.
In the history of access,
the Princeton Photographs
Division Collections,
card catalogs represented a
flexible, cost effective form
of access when compared
with other access methods
that had their benefits but
also considerable drawbacks.
With picture research in particular,
users often don't know what
they want until they see it.
The contents of a picture
and more indefinable aspects
of the composition
are especially crucial
in the selection stage of searching.
So one of the means of access
implemented in the early days
of the Princeton Photographs
Division was
to place the pictures
in files for browsing.
Direct, effective, satisfying.
But unless one could invest
the money and space needed
to file multiple copies of the
images under different headings,
it also meant deciding on
the one element of an image
that seemed most prominent,
most likely to be sought.
If it's a picture of
calamity Jane for instance,
probably anyone wanting to
know what the frontier scout
and wild west show performer
looked like would be pleased
to find this picture under her
name once one figures out which
of her many names she went by
and what you should look under.
But there are other elements of
the picture that could also be
of interest, the setting, which
turns out to be the grounds
of the Pan American Exposition
in Buffalo, New York in 1901,
the photographer and copyright
holder C.D. Arnold, even the horse.
Researchers studying the exposition
or the photographic techniques
of C.D. Arnold or horses used
in entertainment at the turn
of the 20th century would miss out.
The handy 3 by 5 card bearing a
description of the image and filed
under multiple access points
opened new paths for research.
This point may seem obvious,
but filing descriptions
in a card catalog also
promoted collocation.
We had to deliberately include a
name heading or a subject heading
to file under and with
well established principles
of authority control, consistent
use of headings enabled the user
to count on all of the photographs
of Martha Canary to
be listed together.
And cross references could
easily be built in to lead
from her better known
name Calamity Jane
to the authorized heading
at the time.
But a heading that has since changed
in the LC name authority file
where the authorized name
is now Calamity Jane.
This demonstration that
in cataloging as in life,
change is ceaseless,
also illustrates
that with each new technology
comes new challenges.
Cross references were easy to
build in, not so easy to maintain,
a point I'll return to in a minute.
But back to my salute to the
flexibility of the card catalog.
One feature that was exploited to
the fullest in our reading room is
that staff organized the
contents of each catalog devoted
to a particular pictorial format
in a way that made the most sense
for the items they led to.
While author, title, subject
catalogs are the norm,
with our fine prints, for instance,
the entries are organized by century
and within that by the
name of the artist.
Talk about visualization.
Just a glance at the
drawers gives a sense
of the bulk dates of our collection.
Since staff could record all kinds
of information on a 3 by 5 card,
in this catalog staff went
beyond mere cross references
to incorporate the
authority record itself
with all the research
it represented.
And lest you think that
we traded the you know it
when you see it element of
access solely for word headings,
I'll point out that with our
historical print collection we
revived the notion that
seeing the picture as early
in the search process as possible
is a vast aid to research.
Did the fabulous 3 by 5
card technology solve all
of our access problems?
What am I going to say?
No. Just imagine how
labor intensive it was
to paste those little
pictures on the cards.
Combine that with the work involved
in producing multiple cards,
adding headings to them and filing
them and maintaining headings
and cross references with changing
cataloging rules was also a
challenge, and the results could
be pretty messy in the absence
of training in library hand.
With the growing collection, it now
totals nearly 16 million items even
when we describe on a
single card an entire group
of images rather then
describing the items one by one,
the labor involved meant that
there were thousands of images
that didn't even get this
level of description not
to mention the physical
preparation that would be needed
to make it possible to serve
the materials being described.
Digitization and machine readable
cataloging enabled us to describe,
index and display images
in far greater quantity
with far greater speed and ease
and enabled correspondingly greater
speed and ease in the searching end.
Keyword access to all the words
in the records whether headings
or not took the pressure off of
the analysis and precision required
to assign authorized headings
and the maintenance
that comes with that.
Although we are still big
believers in authority control
and controlled vocabulary, we assess
collections to determine what level
of cataloging can practically be
applied in light of the likely use
of the images and other
characteristics of the material.
Sometimes that means relying
on words found in various parts
of the description as in these
catalog records from images related
to the Pan American Exposition.
Catalog records for some materials
consist at least initially primarily
of information that came
on or with the items,
generally recorded as
a transcribed title.
That's the case for instance
with our 35,000 glass negatives
from the National Photo
Company Collection.
The transcription provides
searchable words but we've lost some
of the benefits of collocation,
that one stop shopping satisfaction
of knowing you found
all the relevant entries
under the authorized
name or subject heading.
Therefore, we must
remind searchers to think
of the different ways names
can be spelled and expressed.
Similarly, it's important
to think of synonyms
that might have been used for a
topic and to think about the words
that might have been current
in the 1910's and 1920's
when the images were
made and captioned.
For the researcher interested in
early auto travel, think roadsters,
not our standard subject
heading of automobiles.
As you can see, sometimes
particularly with large collections
of negatives, very few
words come with an item
and sometimes not at all.
To provide maximum access
as immediately as possible,
we take advantage of digital
visual access in a way
that the card catalog
couldn't have readily provided.
Related images are
often physically next
to each other in the collection.
Exposing that arrangement
offers an added form of access.
Here, someone interested
in auto racing
at the Baltimore Washington Speedway
in Laurel would probably
be delighted
to find this uncaptioned photo
beside one that had a basic caption
that mentions the location and date.
Do you suppose there's a
metaphor somewhere in the fact
that I've switched modes
from transportation
to Calamity Jane's horse to speeding
cards of the early 20th century?
Electronic data and digital
technology have expanded
exponentially the universe
of what we can make available
from our vast and varied
collections.
But in my final ode
to the card catalog,
I'll note that there
wasn't intangible
or maybe entirely tangible
quality that came with being able
to see the size and
scope of a card catalog.
You had a physical sense of the
universe of data you were searching.
With many of our online systems,
it's now harder to get a sense
of the whole pool of
data when it's searching
so it becomes more
challenging to figure
out whether one search has
been truly comprehensive.
Helping researchers to picture
the information universe we're
presenting and how to navigate
that universe is part
of our ongoing mission.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Christopher Cronin:
The microphones are going
to go like this all day.
Well, thank you and
good afternoon everyone.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Susan asked me to talk
about how the University
of Chicago built its catalog,
particularly around its
distinctive area studies collections
and in particular [inaudible]
languages or scripts rather.
And I imagine I was asked
also because of my connection
to the cataloging community and
the PCC, but I have to confess.
I did -- I never cataloged
in [inaudible] script myself.
So my solution to this, how
do you develop a presentation
on something I have no personal
experience with was to talk
to my colleagues, many of whom
in technical services were
around when we managed the card
catalog and also some members
of our collection development team.
And what they told me interestingly
even though I talked to all
of them independently and
separately came into several kind
of recurring themes, and some
of them we've already
heard a little bit about.
And the first was how
the card catalog
over time reflected
histories of our language.
And our Slavic and eastern European
studies bibliographer gave me this
great example of how
pre 1917 publications
for Russian materials
had to be treated
and approached in very
different ways.
It turns out that 100
years ago tomorrow
on May 11, that's tomorrow right?
May 11, 1917 the Soviets, of
course, wanted to remove as much
of the [inaudible] history as
possible,and they created a group
that I think I see some
coin people in the crowd,
some PCC [inaudible] people in the
crowd, a great group for the PCC.
It sounds exactly like
what we would do now.
The assembly for considering
simplification of the orthography.
Doesn't that sound like a group,
the PCC would form reporting
to the standing committee on
standards or something like that?
So they wanted to modernize the
language after the czarist period.
So if a book was written
pre 1917 orthography for --
in Russian, the bibliographers,
the subject specialist,
the public services librarians
over time had to including now,
this metadata is still represented
in North American databases,
certainly in worldcat to the extent
that it has really
never been harmonized
and in our [inaudible] guide
for this collection there is
still a note that says if you want
to determine if we have a pre 1917
publication in our online catalog
or a database such as worldcat,
you will have to retransliterate
the Soviet title back
into the old orthography to find it.
And so whether you like it or not,
you have to be a linguist to get
to some of this data
and what surprised me
about this was we keep trying
to uncover hidden collections all
the time even ones we've cataloged,
but are not really usable or
findable and certainly this came
to the [inaudible] for me when
I was talking to my colleagues.
Certainly also for this part of the
world there were different histories
and practices governing
transliteration,
and I learned from my colleagues
that that scholarly transliteration
was actually quite different
from the transliteration developed
by the Library of Congress,
nd so even now as our
researchers look
at those early source materials,
we are transliterating a lot
of these things between
the various schemes.
The words identity politics,
this is Washington so come
to the news media all the time.
It's a catchy phrase,
but certainly reflected.
This is just one example
of one country in less
than a century how many time it
changed its identity and its name.
And a colleague, I wrote her
quote from an email she sent me.
Said, "Corporate entries in the
card catalog told the entire history
of an institution," bethat
a government or a country
or any other corporate body.
All of these nuances of the
deep impact of the evolutions
of our language, culture, politics,
geographies, the identities
of our people were not only
reflected in our card catalog
but required a much
deeper connection
between the cataloging operations
and the public services operations
of the library than we do now.
And one of the things that
I meant to bring with me
but I didn't was a manual that was
created really by the catalogers
to help reference staff understand
how to navigate the catalog,
and now we think you
search and that's --
use the word search, you think type.
But searching the catalog was an
intensely physical activity back
then and required knowing not
just how the catalog worked
but many other reference tools
like [inaudible] and so forth.
Sorry, Susan also asked me to talk
about whether Chicago is ever
a customer of LC's cards,
and folklore has it we did get the
cards but not for the card catalog,
for selectors to make
purchase decisions.
I don't know if they were the
same cards that we would have put
in the card catalog, but it -- what
the problem was was that our ability
to use LC's cards really came down
to this tiny little square footage
on the card, the call number.
We built our collections at times
while LCC classification was still
being developed and there
was decades of history
of catalogers building
local classification schemes
for our collections.
That was very hard
to give up, and we --
someone used the word
intellectual contributions earlier,
and certainly there would have been
a deep connection to that work,
and I would imagine led
to us being so delayed
in becoming an OCLC member.
We did not join OCLC until 1989.
So most of our copy cataloging if we
did it came through the tape loads
from LC, but we also weren't
contributing our original cataloging
until quite late, and so
those deep traditions,
the expertise in cataloging that
Chicago acquired over time then also
as soon as we went into
OCLC, I think that spirit
of cooperation and
sharing took hold.
We joined the PCC,
and I did get a chance
to read the book a
couple of days ago.
One of the histories
I learned in there was
that Charles Cutter attempted to
do something that I think the PCC
and certainly all of its
participating libraries,
mine even this week itself trying
to get better metadata directly
from publishers as close to the
time of publishing as possible.
And if I can quote you first,
[inaudible] I thought it was great.
The quote the plan was to
goad publishers into working
with Charles Cutter on cataloging
their own books through insertion
of a paper slip containing
the bibliographic information
that could be used by libraries.
The response from libraries
was tepid.
I was going to make you insert the
blank, but I'll give you a pass.
They viewed the scheme
with skepticism
and doubted it would
provide the final answers
to their cataloging needs.
So I don't know when that happened
but certainly a long time ago
and more proof that the more things
change the more they stay the same.
We still struggle with that one.
So we certainly, of
course, this book is mostly
about the public catalog, but
I'm a technical services person,
and I wanted to know what
was managing the card catalog
like on the back end?
Certainly we had gigantic
shelf lists.
And one of my staff, our head
of serials, Renee Martin,
showed me this holdings
card from the University
of Chicago Serials Department.
It is an annual report, a check
in card for the annual report
from the town clerk presumably
from Sidney, Australia.
Doesn't say Australia on it.
And we see that it was regularly
being received through 1989
in unbound status and at
some point there's blanks.
So by the absence of data you
can assume we stopped getting it.
And then you can also
assume someone was curious,
where is all of this stuff
and tried to claim it.
I don't know if they would have
called it claiming back then,
but that's what we
would call it now,
and you see there's a
handwritten note at the bottom
of the card dated 2/1/1941.
It's not an ISO format so
I can't tell you whether
that means February 1 or January 2.
It's got a Roman numeral in it.
That's probably a convention
for something.
I can't tell you what.
But the note says will
be forwarded end of war.
And I think what was so
fascinating about that was preserved
in these catalog cards even
just the management side
of things are these
realities of information flow
through our histories during
times of global conflict
and clearly how difficult
it was to relay information
and get publications during
a period of time of conflict,
but interestingly in a part of
the world you don't normally think
of as being the theater of
war at that particular time,
clearly a challenge nonetheless.
I could go into a story about the
abbreviation for the word analytics,
but I will considering the
esteemed venue I will not,
but I will tell you that
last month I mandated
that all 250 something
thousand instances
of that abbreviation be spelled
out in full in our catalog
because we display the
entire MARK record now,
and I did not want that in there.
So we got rid of that.
So this was another note shared
with me from the shelf list
that demonstrates that the future
is indeed longer than the past
and the struggles that our
colleagues faced back then were
at their core the same
that we struggle with now.
This is a note that said we really
want to do analytics for this,
and we will do this
if ever any time.
And I think what we have learned
is there will really never be
more time.
As a cataloging manager
who has inherited the sins
of many forefather's poor
judgment in treatment decisions,
I can say we no longer kid ourselves
that there will be more time.
We either do it or we don't do it.
Lastly, I would love to
thank you all for listening.
I want to thank you for inviting
me to speak at this event if only
because it provided me with an
important reminder of the history
of my profession, the history of my
library for giving me another reason
to appreciate the precious
fewof my colleagues remaining
in my organization who remember what
it was like and how that historical
and institutional knowledge
of how we essentially became
who and what we are today.
One of them, I just want to put
her picture up is June Farris.
She is our Slavic and Eastern
European bibliographer.
I got many stories from her,
some so scandalous I couldn't
even repeat them to you today,
partly because they involved
the Library of Congress.
The juiciest ones really did.
This historical knowledge,
this connection to our past is
at grave risk as our colleagues
retire and these histories retire
with them and this book
that LC has published will
in no short measure
ensure that those memories
of our cataloging humanity
perhaps even a few strands
of our cataloging DNA will be
captured in there forever more
and I want to thank the Library
of Congress for that as well.
Its been a great privilege.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Kathy Woodrell: Well, I'm
a little taller than that.
I'm Kathy Woodrell,
and I'm here to talk
about using the main card
catalog in reference work.
So let's see, it's this.
Oh, it's this.
Thank you.
So between 1802 and 1879,
the library had produced
at least 57 printed catalogs.
I won't be reading to you the
entire time let me assure you.
When the Jefferson Building opened
in 1897, there was no complete
or current catalog, and the
Librarian of Congress at the time,
John Russell Young, stated that,
"A library without a catalog is
like a ship without a rudder."
The main reading room staff did
have a small drawer compiled
with entries clipped from
these various catalogs
that was kept behind the desk.
Much reliance was placed
on the staff
to remember the books
in the collection.
By 1900, a dictionary catalog
containing 90,000 cards was
on the floor in the
main reading room,
and by 1920, the catalog had grown.
Between 1920 and 1950, the
card catalog occupied a quarter
of the main reading room,
and it grew to fill the current
reference assistance room
that you see pictured here
on the right, the machine
and electronics resources
center, what we call it currently,
and the hallway between the two.
When the catalog was closed in 1980,
it had 22,000 drawers
and 22 million cards.
In 1990 or '89, the catalog
was moved to two deck areas off
of the main reading room and
because the Carnegie steel shelving
in the Jefferson Building actually
provides structural support
for the building, the circular
card catalog cases that were
in the main reading room couldn't
be used and so we appealed --
the library appealed to
libraries around the country
to send us their card
catalog cases cabinets
since they weren't
using them anymore
and we received many of those.
Now, the card catalog is
on decks 16 and 33 just off
of the main reading room.
These images show one aisle
of the main catalog --
card catalog on deck 33 and part
of the shelves housing just
A through P on the right.
Because the cabinets were
received from a variety
of different libraries, the catalog
is not aesthetically pleasing,
but it is fully functional.
And here are some caveats
for fully functional.
With 22 million cards, a
misfiled card is a lost card
and a lost card can be a lost item.
Over the years, sometimes
researchers will just rip the card
out of the card catalog
to bring it to us
so we can retrieve it for them.
Or they take the card to show their
uncle that his book actually is
in the Library of Congress.
In the movie J. Edgar which was
filmed at the Library of Congress,
Leonardo D'Caprio is
actually shown ripping a card
out of the card catalog.
Several years ago, we discovered
that all of the subject cards
for birds had disappeared
and had to be replaced.
When I began in the
main reading room,
I was assigned a terrific
mentor, Tom Mann.
28 years later, he still
has lessons for me,
but one of my first lessons was
red tipped cards are subject cards.
For many years, we were
under the impression actually
until I started working on this
presentation that those numbers
in the card catalog that looked
like fractions were
actually Jefferson numbers,
and here's an example of a
card that with the call number
that looks like a fraction.
There were two people
who could convert them.
I remember one of their names,
Jefferson numbers converted.
Who you going to call?
Sigrid Milner.
I'm sure she's no longer
here, but you could call one
of these two people
from the reference desk
and they would give you
the accurate call number
for the book that had that fraction.
So I'm hoping some of you who
are catalogers will be able
to explain this fractional system.
I don't recognize it.
So -- but you can see in this card
that the number has been crossed out
and the new call number
has been replaced.
[ Inaudible ]
Yes, sir. I wanted to tell
you some stories about some
of the people who've
come to request help
and had to use the card catalog.
A few of my colleagues
worked with a researcher
who was a handwriting specialist,
and he came to the Library
of Congress to study the
library hand as found
in the main card catalog.
In the 1880's, much was written
about handwriting by Melville Dewey,
the American Library Association
and by Charles Cutter now known
to us primariliy as part of the
call number after the period.
So prior to 1887, Melville Dewey
began to promote library handwriting
or the library hand
as it was also called.
He preferred the vertical style.
He was interested in speed,
efficiency and legibility.
Should you be interested
in library hand or for
that matter telegraphic hand,
railway hand or telegram hand,
those actually exist, you can
see David Caminsky's website.
I've included it on
the slide so you can --
and I will say that the article
on library hand is
actually quite interesting.
Another story involving my
colleague Abby Yokelson.
A few years ago.
She got a written letter
from a researcher
who was compiling a bibliography
on author Wilkie Collins.
He had seen an entry in the National
Union Catalog for an edition
of Collins' Woman in White,
The Tale of an Amorphous Woman
Who Had Escaped from an Asylum.
LC was listed as the
only owning library.
In March of 2006, Abby
first found the NUC entry
and then she searched
the card catalog.
On the card was a handwritten
note that I've circled
on this and it says not found.
As Abby examined the card, a
chill wind blew through the deck
as she realized that the note
had been written 100 years ago
to the day.
We've been dealing with pre
MARK records for a long time,
and one of the ways that we deal
with pre MARK records is by going
to the card catalog to see
where the mistake was made.
I always heard that pre MARK was
actually input by Scottish clerks
or Scottish housewives, but --
and I don't actually know that.
Much was actually lost
in translation.
So I'm making a bit of a joke here,
but things were lost in translation.
The cards in the card catalog
often include content notes,
series records, holdings
records, cross references,
records for uniform titles,
automated records derived
from them were often created
using a limited profile
of transferable information
and the automated format often
dropped unique characteristics
and sometimes eliminated
file information.
Copy catalog protocols for machine
readable records often [inaudible]
local information in looking
for other information.
So issues with pre MARK,and
I have an example here
of something called
porcupine's political sensor.
You'll notice on the
card that it says office.
That was an early designation
for rare book.
And that is indeed where this is.
But I wanted to show you the
other cards behind this card
and all the information that
was kept on each of these cards.
So the online catalog record for
the political sensor does indicate
that there are four
rare book collections
where this title can be found
but much of the information
on these cards is now missing.
To effectively respond to a
querie involving older materials,
it's essential to consult
the main card catalog
and perhaps divisional catalogs,
the copyright card catalog,
the shelf list, the [inaudible]
catalog, the National Union Catalog,
bibliographies, reference
sources and colleagues using these
and other sources in
concert is invaluable.
When assisting researchers
seeking historical information,
the card catalog is
an essential element.
It is the authority for
anything published prior to 1968,
and many people don't realize
that the first two aisles
of the catalog hold
just periodical titles.
And those records are duplicated
in the main card catalog.
So these are just some
examples of things
that are found in the catalog.
So many items in the catalog aren't
reflected in the online catalog,
and many, many of the library's
foreign language materials
and periodicals in foreign languages
are only found in the card catalog.
The older things that have
been converted are primarily
English language.
In addition, changed subject
headings is a very important topic.
For example, aeroplanes was the --
used to be the term,
we know use airplanes.
Moving pictures is
now motion pictures.
Negroes is now African Americans.
There's so many examples of changed
subject terms, but in the area
of the card catalog we keep
two copies of the ninth edition
of Library of Congress
subject headings.
That is the edition that was in
place when the catalog was closed.
Since there is no global search
and replace in the card catalog,
e are reliant on those older terms
for identifying older materials.
And the card here shows the
previous term for Auschwitz,
which I would never
have been able to spell.
I want to tell you a story
about a card catalog success
in which I was assigned a question
froma woman in Texas named Gretchen.
She wanted to find
another woman named Eileen.
They were pen pals when
they were young teenagers.
And the only information
she had was this.
Eileen had contracted polio and
Gretchen had read an article
about Eileenin a magazine
published some time
in the late 1940's or early 1950's.
She remembered Eileen's
address but not her last name
or any other information.
She didn't remember the name
of the journal or the date.
So step one, I had an address.
I determined that the apartment
building in New York City
where Eileen had lived
had been razed.
It was now a parking lot.
So then I went to the reader's
guide for periodical literature
and started looking for
articles about a young girl
who was recovering from polio.
I found no entries.
I then used the reference book
that listed magazines produced
for women's interests
to identify titles
that were available around 1950.
Most of those titles were either
not indexed or partially indexed.
I then used the card catalog
to get call numbers for several
of those possible titles.
Are you getting the fact that
I can be like a dog with a bone
with a reference question
because I can.
So I started looking.
I went to the stacks, and I
eliminated many journal titles
and looked at more tables of
contents than I cared to admit.
There was one bound volume
of the Ladies Home Companion
missing from the stacks.
But the space was there.
So I kept watching and
returning and finally
after about two months the
volume was on the shelf again.
I opened it up.
The table of contents said that
the article was in that journal.
I was so excited.
When I turned to the page,
it had been razor bladed out.
So I found another library that
had that article and I had --
it was North Texas State
University Library.
I had them send the
article to Gretchen.
Gretchen when she received
the article called
to say what Eileen's
last name had been
and fortunately it was
Dichek [assumed spelling],
somewhat unusual and not Jones.
So I was able to find a
brother just using the internet,
and I reunited Eileen and
Gretchen after more than 50 years.
Thank you and thanks
to the card catalog.
Although we no longer
have the beautiful cases
that formerly resided in
the main reading room,
we have all the information
included in them.
So please, come to the main
reading room, use the card catalog
and here's a current picture of it.
Although not an option for
the Library of Congress,
libraries that have gotten rid
of their card catalogs are
doing really creative things,
and so even though they're
no longer in use, this is --
images from the San
Francisco Public Library.
They hired an artist to get
people to draw on different cards
that meant something to
them and the upper floor
in the San Francisco Public
Library is wallpapered
with these artistic cards.
Here are other examples of
art and creativity workshops
at libraries using catalog cards.
Here's an organization called
the Library as Incubator Project.
With that card catalog
corset, who knew?
And here's one from Columbus
State University with all kinds
of creativity made out
of card catalog cards.
It looks like as well as
cards -- the checkout cards.
So as the decorative arts
specialist, I would be remiss not
to share exciting possibilities for
card catalog cabinets and cases,
and you might ask where
would I get such a thing?
Well, there's always the magic of
eBay, Google, Craigslist, Etsy,
flea markets, and that will allow
you to find organizational zeal.
Look at all the things people
have put in their card catalogs.
And you can keep track of
your items, and if you insist
on using your card
catalog alphabetically,
there's alsop always Asti
Spumante [inaudible].
So on behalf of the card catalog off
of the main reading room and myself,
I would like to thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennifer Baxmeyer: Well,
I can't compete with wine
in a catalog card -- card catalog,
but I'm going to talk a little bit
about how we at Princeton are using
RDF vocabulary such as bibframe
which Beacher mentioned to explore
relationships in the inscribed
and annotated material that we found
in the library of Jacque Derrida
and what we're doing to help expose
those relationships in the form
of link data on the semantic web.
So little over two years ago,
Princeton University acquired
the personal working library
of Jacque Derrida who was an
Algerian born French philosopher
who is considered probably one
of the foremost thinkers
of the 20th century.
This acquisition was significant
for us because the library consists
of about 16,000 items including
books and other material
and Derrida's library was pretty
much an immersive environment,
eaning that it represents his
sort of lifetime of reading.
For Derrida, the active reading
was not really a passive process.
He was actively engaged
in what he was reading,
and he annotated much of it.
These annotations included
everything from [inaudible]
to dog eared and paper clipped
pages and pages with post it notes
and other inserted material.
In addition, many of the books
in Derrida's library are actually
presentation volumes bearing
personal inscriptions from other
philosophers and theorists as well
as from a wide range of admirers.
Today we've identified
about 6300 books
that have personal inscriptions.
These inscriptions give us a
glimpse into Derrida's global social
and intellectual network.
Perhaps equally important
if not more so is the fact
that Derrida himself annotated
many of these inscribed volumes.
He took note of where others
mentioned him in the books,
and he often annotated
those particular pages.
As a result, we're able
to gain additional insight
into his reactions about what
others were saying about him
because like most authors and
writers, Derrida cared a lot
about what other people
said about him.
So as we've seen from the
previous presentations, we've --
libraries have a long history
of organizing information,
both for the purpose of preserving
knowledge and also for making
that knowledge available
to anyone searching for it.
We've made significant strides in
organizing information beginning
with simple lists of books
engraved on clay tablets
to the rich descriptive data found
in our online discovery systems.
The next logical step then is to
share that rich data on the web
so that it's value could be
appreciated beyond the library.
Unfortunately, one of the biggest
obstacles to exposing library data
on the web is in the way that the
web can actually understand it is a
reliance on the MARK
format to encode our data.
MARK has served us really
quite well for half a century,
but libraries are pretty much
the only industry using MARK
so our data doesn't play well with
everybody else's data on the web.
So we need to move away from MARK
to a framework that allows us
to create machine actionable
data that is persistent
and easily understood
by web crawlers.
So currently, we present
data to library users
through our online
discovery systems.
In addition for archival
collections, we create finding aids
that give more detail about
collections than we can include
in our bibliographic descriptions.
At Princeton, the finding aid
for Derrida's library presents
the material in the order
that he left it as far as we know.
Some of it arrived
in boxes out of order
and anyway, it was kind of a mess.
But anyway, which is
useful for researchers
because again it emphasizes
the context
and gives them an idea
of his social networks.
But the problem with
finding aids just
like with bibliographic records
encoded in MARK, much of the data
and the finding aid which uses
encoded archival description is
mostly textual.
For the Derrida library,
our rare books
and special collections
staff created identifiers
to reflect the original
shelf order of the material,
meaning which wall the book was on,
which case on the wall, which shelf
and what position on the shelf.
So this is really interesting to
researchers because they can see,
oh we've got Vampire
Diaries next to Death
and Transfiguration next
to Fifty Shades of Gray.
I'm making up stuff, but by being
able to see how things were shelved,
the researchers can deduce maybe
or come up with assumptions
about what he was thinking or
what he might have been working
on at the time he received
a particular volume.
But the problem with those
identifiers is that with EAD,
the Encoded Archival Description,
the identifiers are
basically just kind of stuck
in what's basically a big ordered
list, and so the types of quering
that needs to be done
isn't easily done.
So this is where we are right now.
We have rich data about library
resources and collections,
but that data has mostly been
captured in text strings in a format
that most of the web
does not understand.
So I'll talk a little bit more
about Derrida in a minute,
but let's go back to
the online catalog.
So online catalogs
contain rich information
about the resources we've
been curating for centuries.
What if, though, we were able
to create an enhanced
discovery environment for users
from the wealth of nonlibrary
data sources on the web
that describe those same works,
people and other entities
that we represent in our catalogs.
We can use linked data
to help us get there.
Some libraries are
already experimenting
with enhancing their discovery
systems with information pulled
in from resources outside
of the library.
What if we could pull in
data from Wikipedia directly
into our online catalog like
I have shown on this mockup
in the middle of the page?
Or what if we could provide visual
representations of the relationships
between authors when a user
does a search by author?
Perhaps we could create API's that
could display interactive graphs
of relationships for
our users directly
from within our online catalogs.
The possibilities for serendipitous
discovery suddenly become limitless.
In order to reach the point
of creating enhanced discovery
environments for our users as well
as reaching the point where our
carefully crafted and curated
and nurtured library data
is exposed on the open web,
we need to free that data.
We need to free it from
the confines of the library
so that a user searching the web
will not only retrieve results
from commercial enterprises such
as Amazon.com but will see links
to resources held by institutions
like the Library of Congress
or University of Chicago
or Princeton.
Once we do this, we will pave the
way for new knowledge creation.
The project we're working on at
Princeton with Derridas library aims
to create a set of data that can
be used by researchers and scholars
to learn more about
Derrida and his social
and global intellectual network
and to easily answer potential
research questions such as
which inscriptions did Derrida make
comments on or Derrida is not known
for his works on religion
so where did he get all
of these books on Judaism?
Oncewe record the data using
persistent identifiers instead
of strings of text and
model it using a standard
such as the resource
description framework or RDF,
which is the standard model used
for exchanging data on the web,
e will be able to publish
that data on the open web
so that it can be used by
others however they may wish.
Perhaps a researcher is interested
in finding out what kinds
of people were sending
books to Derrida?
We might be able to
assist that research
by creating an interface driven
by linked data that will allow her
to form complex queries about
the items in Derrida's library.
Or perhaps another researcher is
interested in seeing visualizations
that show the geographic locations
of people who sent books to Derrida
and how these changed over time.
That researcher could take
the persistent identifier
from names we've coded in our
bibliographic descriptions,
pull in data for geographic
locations from something
like geonames and then import
all this into a spreadsheet,
upload the spreadsheet into an
online tool such as [inaudible]
which was created at Stanford, and
this would allow that researcher
to visualize and analyze
the relationships over time.
But back to our question
of how we might get there?
The approach we're using at
Princeton is two pronged.
For the inscriptions, we're using
the web annotation data model,
which is the official --
which actually became an
official worldwide web consortium
recommendation earlier this year.
For the bibliographic data
that described the books
in Derrida's library,
we're using bibframe.
We found that the core purpose
of the web annotation data model
fits well with the Derrida material.
The model states annotations are
typically used to convey information
about a resource or
associations between resources.
For our purposes, the
inscription itself is an annotation
so the inscription is a
body and then the public
in which the inscription
is written is the target.
So then we have a model that
we can work with and use
that web annotation data model.
So I mentioned earlier that Derrida
sometimes annotated the books he
received as gifts.
Here's one of our favorite
inscriptions from the collection
that we came across when we were
digitizing the inscriptions.
You can see that Derrida
has indicated his opinion
of the [inaudible] by writing
hypocrite explanation point
to the left of the transcription.
And this was actually an
interesting case in modeling
because not only do we have the one
annotation being the inscription
of the book to Derrida but
then we have Derrida's shade
on that particular person
as another annotation.
By using the web annotation
data model and RDF,
we're able to capture the
relationships between the work
that was given to Derrida,
the person who sent the work
and Derrida himself in such a way
that the data can be represented
as a collection of statements
about those relationships.
Each with a subject, a
predicate and an object.
These are called triple statements
because they have three parts
and the premise of linked
data is that the subject
of one triple can be the
object of another triple.
So this is -- I don't know if
you've seen those linked data graphs
with just like all
these lines and circles.
This is what is driving linked
data, these relationships.
You have an object and a subject
connected with a predicate
and then there's another subject
that's the same as this object.
And then we start to have
more complex relationships
that we can easily see
in our bibliographic
data that we have today.
So and also because each triple
statement will have a unique
identifier,a computer can derive
meaning from those statements
in a way that's impossible
with text screens.
Another thing that we --
and I thought about this --
this wasn't part of my
presentation so I'm digressing.
When we were learning about sort
of the history of the card catalog,
I remembered at Princeton we got rid
of our card catalog a few years ago
and a lot of professors were
really upset about it going away
because for many of them that was
their first place for research.
Snd their area of expertise --
you'd go to that section
of the card catalog
and see just documents written
on the back of the cards,
in the margins and everything.
And we've lost that.
We lost that when we went
to the online catalog.
And what's nice about the web
annotation data model and the idea
of going forward with linked data is
that we could potentially
provide a way for researchers
to start annotating the way
they did the card catalog
because the web annotation
data model is set
up where a person can make
an assertion about a thing
and show the [inaudible]
of that statement so again,
it brings it back to
having the researchers
and scholars more intimately
associated with the catalog record
so that's another exciting
thing that I thought
of while I was sitting there
that doesn't have anything
to do with what's there.
So using bibframe which is -- it's
in the second version right now --
will allow us to describe the gift
books in Derrida's library using --
again using triples with persistent
identifiers which are critical
in order for linked
data to actually work.
We are actually able to put
persistent identifiers in MARK,
and a lot of libraries
including Princeton are beginning
to add these persistent
identifiers called URI's
to their bibliographic records
in preparation for linked data.
But the key difference
between bibframe and MARK is
that bibframe uses RDF, the resource
description framework conventions
and MARK does not.
So bibframe is able to
communicate, if you will,
with the rest of the
web where MARK is not.
New data models expressed in RDF
are necessary in order to shift
to the linked data environment we're
counting on to help us free our data
so that it can be used in
new and interesting ways
and provide enhanced discovery
environments for library users.
Bibframe is the model
that Princeton,
other experimenters are
using to realize the future
for library data on
the semantic web.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Beacher Wiggins:
Well, thank you everyone.
No doubt, everyone has
something to take away
from the presentations today.
Are there any thoughts
from any of the presenters?
Jennifer [inaudible] hers is into
her presentation as she was talking.
Anything striking to the rest
of you listening to the others
of you speak before we ask
if the audience has any
questions or comments?
>> I'm just thankful that I deleted
the last line of my presentation,
which was a picture of a card
catalog from our collection
that is now used to store
wine at a friend's house.
So I didn't step on
your toes with that.
>> Beacher Wiggins: Questions
or comments from the audience?
Yes.
[ Inaudible ]
>> There seems to be a
[inaudible] of articles
in [inaudible] online publications
such as Atlas Obscure [inaudible]
who seem to have just
discovered now card catalogs.
Atlas Obscure wrote a long one.
You'll appreciate this,
about how the card catalog,
the Library of Congress is
gathering dust in the basement.
And actually I kind of use that
every day in [inaudible] materials
to verify holding, and
if it's gathering dust,
it's because someone
doesn't clean it.
The [inaudible] articles
again seemed
to have discovered catalog cards
in general and just [inaudible]
about the amount of
detail found on said cards.
And while part of me thinks
well, it's great that cataloging
in general and metadata creation
is getting sort of wider attention,
on the other hand, I have
concerns that the manner
in which this is treated makes it
sound as though A, we don't include
that kind of detail anymore,
which we do, and not annotations
but the actual cataloging and
B, that what we do is some kind
of [inaudible] lost art that is
no longer practiced and again
in my opinion anything
that makes us sound
like we're practicing an [inaudible]
lost art leads to things like oh,
we don't need libraries anymore.
They just do those
lovely historic things
like write card catalogs
and nifty hand.
And I was wondering how
you felt about what seems
to be the even prior to the
book the sort of re-emergence
of the card catalog and catalog
cards in sort of popular culture?
>> I would just like to
say I spoke with Tom Mann
at length writing this book, and
I think the quote's in the book,
and he wanted to make clear
the cards were not kept
as he said I think for
the texture of the wood
and the sort of nostalgia.
He wanted to emphasize their
continued utility for cataloging
and reference staff
here at the library.
So I hope that does come
through in the book.
>> Beacher Wiggins: Jennifer.
>> Jennifer Baxmeyer: Of course, I
have to respond to my friend, Deb.
But I think one of the problems --
I mean, one of the reasons
that there's this perception
that we're doing -- that we're not
doing the same thing anymore is
because we hide so much of
it in our online catalogs
because we've assumed that the
users don't want to see that.
They want the Google
experience with the blank screen.
When they get the search
result, they just want the title
and the call number so
they can go to the stacks.
So we've hidden so much information
that I think there might even
be a whole generation of people
who don't realize the work
that actually still goes
into creating a bibliographic
description and since they're able
to go to Google and find things,
they don't realize the
intellectual work that goes
into creating descriptions
because --
and I think that's one way we've
kind of shot ourselves in the foot,
and we're having to
make ourselves --
trying to make ourselves
relevant now
because we've hidden
so much of that work.
>> Beacher Wiggins: Yes.
>> So I also work in the
main reading room with Kathy,
and somebody up there
mentioned institutional memory.
And Kathy had mentioned David
Caminsky coming in and looking
at our catalog in terms
of library hand.
It was fascinating because he
was pretty sure he could identify
which library school various
catalogers had gone to based
on the style of handwriting.
It was amazing to me.
But predays of cell phone cameras,
we used to occasionally have
to give people permission
to take out the rod
from the catalog and
photocopy a catalog.
And he had very good reason for
needing to do that so we started
to carefully take these apart.
Kathy had mentioned it's a hodge
podge of catalog cases and drawers
and kinds of things, and I
think we came up with five
or six different methods to get the
rods out, and one was really simple.
You just unscrewed it,
and another one had
like a hidden button,
but there are also keys.
There are a couple of different
kinds of ways of loosening the rod
and Cheryl Adams inherited
some of these keys
when Sheridan Harvey retired, and
we had to be around to get the keys
or open the catalog, and
I can't even remember how
to do most of them.
So we decided in terms
of succession planning
and institutional memory
have a staff meeting.
We needed to train some
of our younger colleagues.
So we brought in all the drawers and
all the keys and taught everyone how
to use them because it just
doesn't come up very often,
but when it does, you need to
know how to open those drawers.
>> Yeah, if I could add to that.
Kay Giles and Tom Yee, I
spoke with both of them
when I was writing this book.
And I forget which one but they told
a story of there used to be back
in the day staff members who
would stand by the card catalogs
when somebody pulled a rod out
and knocked the whole drawer over
and the cards would go everywhere.
They were masters of
quickly refiling the cards
in the correct order and
getting the rod back in there.
>> Beacher Wiggins: There is
a question there and here.
>> Okay, I'm just curious
about the workflow.
Once MARK was being pushed in 1969
or 1970, not everybody was going
to be doing the actual
cataloging [inaudible] information.
The catalog was still
being typed up.
What was the workflow -- that
information was going to be inputted
into a machine readable
system and then --
in other words, what
was the workflow?
You had a book.
Because [inaudible] was still
being -- still being created,
but you had MARK, which
was machine readable.
What was that kind of connection?
>> Beacher Wiggins: Well, I'm
going to speak from memory now
because when I came in, I was
cataloging, we were using cards.
They weren't 3 by 5, but they were
twice that so probably like 4 by 6.
And so we catalogers
typed information on that,
and we had a separate division.
MARK Editorial Division,
I believe was its name
at least in one [inaudible].
All of those cards, if you
will, flowed to that division
and there was staff who then
did the keying into the system.
That system generated information
that produced the card --
the cards themselves
that were done by at
that time I think it was called the
card distribution division I believe
it was, and so everything
flowed from catalogers starting
with the input process, going
through the creation process,
the intellectual process
then the input process
and the MARK Editorial Division
and format and structure,
then that flowing on to the
card distribution service
and the card division.
That was one iteration.
Then it moved onto, we
had [inaudible] terminals
and we finally could actually
input the data into something
that had no intellectual
understanding what was happening,
was just sucking it in, going
some place else and then
that would spew out
the end products.
Then I think maybe by the 80's
or 90's we each had
intellectual desktops
that actually took the things
that we could then manipulate
and do searching and
all that kind of thing.
So it was never [inaudible].
Sort of evolved at the same rate of
the MARK format itself from print
through probably the first decade
of 15 years to the special format,
ound recordings,cardiographic
materials and what not.
So that's a very high
level way it flowed
at that time here at the library.
One more question so people can
at least gather a little
bit for the reception.
>> Hi. Long before
the MARK 2 project,
there was a MARK pilot project,
which was a completely
different format.
The tag was right next
to the field itself.
There was no director.
Before even that, Henriette had
contracted with Larry Bucklin
at [inaudible] to do
a study of this area
and what the details were
I cannot say at this point.
>> Beacher Wiggins: Right.
I had some of all that detail but I
didn't want to go into it for this.
I just wanted to keep it
at a high level, but yes.
Believe me, she told me
about every one of those.
And if I got it wrong, if
I was trying to describe
or write some article for her
I knew it by the next day.
So yes. There were lots of
intricacies and they went
to various pilot stages and recon
projects and some of them got funded
and evolved into something
permanent and some went by the way.
The ony thing that was constant
was the constant evolution
of the format itself.
And more and more becoming engrained
in the library world
like what we're doing.
On that then, we will
end and in the --
>> Yeah, I want to thank a moment
to thank all of our speakers.
It was just a fabulous program.
>> This has ben a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.